Most people find that no idea about nasty insects - especially when they are
in your mouth. But
Have you ever thought that insects may be nutritious and environmentally friendly?
And spread
More than most of our foods? Should we all eat insects?
Compare 100 grams of cockroaches with 100 grams of chicken, beef or pork, and you will find that they are close to the food intake
Of protein but cockroaches have a higher value than essential vitamins and minerals such as
Calcium and zinc
And iron. Similarly kebab-like insects contain little fat and high quantity
Of fiber.
But this is not the reason why you will be included in your diet. Currently there are 1.53 billion
Ha of agricultural crops and 3.38 billion hectares of pasture covering our planet
38% of the land
Which you see on the map used for agriculture and crops. While it needs 200 square meters
Of land
To grow one pound of lamb, it only needs 15 square meters to get one pound of cockroaches
In addition, by 2025, 1.8 billion people are expected to live in a few places
Of fresh water, 70%
Freshwater sources are used only in agriculture! To produce 1 kg
Of beef will require
22,000 liters of water and requires the production of 1 kg of pork will need 3,500 liters, and the production of 1 kg of chicken
It will need 2,300 liters
But to produce 1 kg of cockroaches? It will require 1 liter of water only, because insects
It can be fully woven
Only the food you eat. It is also easy to digest - in fact 80%
Of cockroach body can eat it
And digested, compared to 50% of chickens and 40% of cattle
This is not because our mouths did not taste insects before. For every 100 grams of spinach
50 small insects
Including manic insects, tryps and mites are allowed, and peanut butter also contain
Approximately 30 parts of the insect
Such as heads, bodies and feet for every 100 grams. Even the "Hobbs" are used in the industry
Your favorite beer
250 per 100 grams. Yes - your summer beer may be mined
Of insect juice
More than you expect
So, why do not we eat insects? In fact, insects are consumed in parts of Asia and Latin America
And Africa
In fact, in the capital of the Congo, families eat 300 grams of watermelon
Week, representing 96 tons
Of the annual roaster! While the majority of the Western world are screaming
With shit
If they found an insect in their power! This may be due to the traditions of Western cuisine produced
in a
Colder climates where there are fewer insects, and an increase in crops and animals to eat when the Europeans began
By colonizing the world, they considered eating insects to be wild and primitive
Many noticed
Of indigenous people do it. Ignorant that insects are very nutritious
But since the idea of ​​eating insects would be literally hard to swallow, in case recipes were done
Insect processing techniques evolve and adapt our minds, insects can be the supernatural food
In the future
Beware of Greek yogurt and broccoli, there are new children in the neighborhood
In fact we challenged ourselves to bite some insects ourselves, and tried some recipes
And eat some food
Such as cookies and snack pieces using insect flour, in the latest asapTHOUGHT clips also discussed
Role
And the ability of insects to help solve hunger problems around the world, be sure to click the screen
Or link
In the description box to view it
Subscribe to more weekly videos!